okay after dolly parton gave a million
dollars a few months ago to help fund
the research
for kova 19 vaccine she got one
yesterday
and she's calling anyone who doesn't
want to get it a coward
well hey it's me i'm finally going to
get my vaccine i'm so excited
i've been waiting a while i'm old enough
to get it and i'm smart enough to get it
so i'm very happy that i'm going to get
my mederna shot today
and i wanted to tell everybody that you
should get out there
and do it too i haven't changed one of
my songs to fit the occasion
it goes vaccine vaccine vaccine
vaccine i'm begging of you please don't
hesitate
vaccine vaccine vaccine vaccine
because once you're dead then that's a
bit too late
i know i'm trying to be funny now but
i'm dead serious
about the vaccine i think we all want to
get back to
normal whatever that is and that would
be a great shot in the arm wasn't it
if we could get back to that but anyhow
i just wanted to encourage everybody
because the sooner we get to feeling
better
the sooner we are going to get back to
being normal
so i just want to say to all of you
cowards out there
don't be such a chicken squat get
out there and get shot
stinky got it i got it okay
oh dolly everyone's pretty bad
jeff says dolly's a treasure coat says
love you dolly
uh ali says dolly is a queen the one
thing i am surprised about
in her little speech there um because
she's always so neutral i'm surprised
she calls people cowards
that don't want to get the uh vaccine
i love dolly charles she is a a national
treasure and then she's like the
tennessee auntie that
like you just listen to anything she
says because
like she just has so much knowledge and
experience and all that stuff
but i i love that she's putting she put
her money
where her mouth is and now she's
actually showing us hey don't be afraid
now granted there are a lot of us that
are scared of getting the vaccine
because we don't know if we're gonna end
up walking around parking later or
something like that
but you know i i think that it's um
she's from tennessee
that's how that's how we talk you know
um and i say we because i went to school
in tennessee
so like that's how we talk you know
coward chicken squat whatever but
i think that because she has such a huge
fan base
people are gonna listen to her they're
gonna listen to her because they're like
she's doing it so what do i need to be
afraid of so i
i don't have a problem with her calling
anybody a coward i'm like you know what
she
she did it and she's okay so i shouldn't
have anything to be afraid of yeah
and dolly was you know donald early on
donated a million dollars to
vaccine research and i think that
majority of her donation actually went
to the research on moderna so a lot of
people were like really the person who
gave a million dollars still had to wait
in the line
and wait her turn and she you know and
she
didn't want it any other way i'm sure
dolly could have you know with
everything that she's done you know
gotten the shot earlier but she waited
for her number to be called and she went
and sat in the chair
but but i think that this is exactly why
generation
after generation after generation love
dolly there are 12 year olds right now
who know nothing from anything who love
dolly parton
the first time you see dolly parton she
is the most captivating and infectious
human being ever seen in you she's a
disney character
with sass and she's incredible and you
love
everything about her and if dolly says
it i'm doing it and i think that a lot
of other
people came away and i think that that's
why she called people cowards because
she knows
that even if people are on the fence and
i hate my thing and the masks and
everything else
and if dolly calls you chicken squat
you're like okay well i guess i gotta go
yeah yeah
jennifer says i love dolly since i was
little she's so awesome awesome that she
donated money to the cause
yeah tia says the headline for this was
she got a taste of her own medicine
because of course she donated money to
it yeah so so yeah i think
i think it's fun that she did that and
kind of called people out and we're
seeing
slowly i saw a thing on the news
yesterday that the
percentage of people willing to get the
vaccine has been going up over the last
few weeks because yeah people are seeing
people actually get it so i think it's
good yeah all these people in the public
eye that are doing it
publicly i think it's great yeah because
then you know the few people that that
they're gonna
help effectively get yeah in the long
run yeah it's gonna lead to more people
to get it so
good job dolly and yeah yeah i wish i do
wish that she would have said wear your
masks because
that's one thing that people are still
not doing so i wish um and maybe she
will come out later and say
put your mask on because you know again
we're all going to listen to dolly
because she knows i love it